hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar common symptoms and
presentations of multiple myeloma two
primary care physicians I am Judy or
Oracle Abbott's and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by labyrinth the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by binding site founded by
researchers at the University of
Birmingham binding site has continued to
build on its strong scientific
foundations supporting research and
development within their field and
responding to the changing needs of
patients and clinicians for over 25
years binding site researches develops
manufactures and distributes specialized
immuno diagnostic assays and
instrumentation worldwide and is
committed to improving patient lives
through education collaboration and
innovation to learn more visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor please click on
the CD button at the bottom left corner
and follow the process to receive your
credits you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker OLOL and grin MD
PhD a professor of medicine and chief
attending physician of the myeloma
service at the Memorial sloan-kettering
Cancer Center in New York dr. Ron green
is among the world leaders in the field
of early treatment strategies and
molecular and cell based monitoring of
minimal residual disease
MRD detection in multiple myeloma and
it's precursor States he leads a
translational research
at Memorial sloan-kettering that aims to
discover new treatment paradigms
integrating modern therapy and novel MRD
assays dr. LAN Green has designed and
led the definitive study showing that
all multiple myeloma patients are
preceded by a precursor stage as part of
his ongoing research program he is
studying molecular mechanisms underlying
the trajectory from precursor to
full-blown
multiple myeloma to develop treatment
strategies that would delay prevent and
ultimately define a cure from multiple
myeloma his complete bio is on the lab
routes website dr. Rangoon will now
begin his presentation thank you very
much for having me it's really a great
honor
invited to give his presentation I was
asked to talk about common symptoms and
presentations of patients with multiple
myeloma and that come to primary care
physicians
I'm very busy every week in my clinic I
see a lot of patients and I work at one
of the leading centers here in the
country we see a lot of patients as a
team when I think through all the
referrals I see and I go back and see
how patient percent it's very striking
to me how very diffuse myeloma is and
there is literature on that so for this
presentation I wanted to go over the
literature but also add my own
perspectives my own signing before I go
into the sentence I want to start off by
giving you some high points on myeloma
as you know it's a malignant blood
disease it happens in about 30,000
Americans every year and because
patients are living longer and longer
with the disease in the absence of an
established curative treatment we have
now more than 100,000 people living with
myeloma in the United States which is
mind-blowing it's probably one of the
more common malignancies in the blood
hematologic field it is twice as common
in african-americans compared to whites
for reasons we don't really understand
and it also presents about 10 years
earlier in the african-american
population the treatment nowadays
includes a combination of three drugs
for older patients that may be different
it may only include two drugs and many
of the drugs we use today are not really
conventional chemo drugs there are more
designer drugs like producing inhibitors
immunomodulatory drugs and I think
increasingly we will start using more
antibodies and I do also foresee that
that could even be for drug combinations
coming very soon to the clinics as I
mentioned unfortunately there is not yet
an established cure we're working hard
on that if you look at the overall
survival remembering from when I started
in my career the average survival was
less than two three years and now
patients diagnosed with myeloma that are
in otherwise good shape they can
probably expect a life expectancy of
more than 10 years and this is
increasing so that's fantastic all
patients who do present with multiple
myeloma previously had a diagnosis of
monoclonal gammopathy or smoldering
myeloma or both most of these patients
are unaware that they had that because
they were asymptomatic and I think that
little bit sets the stage for today
patients are running through this
precursor and that leads eventually in
some cases to the development of
multiple myeloma so what are the
symptoms and how long does it take to
diagnose a patient who actually do have
myeloma in the body if you go back and
look in the literature this study from
2013 show on the right that the average
myeloma patients in this study that had
been seeking care was doing so for
almost half a year before the diagnosis
of myeloma was set which is quite a long
time
this actually mimics very well what I'm
used to see in my clinic why is that
well although the symptoms patients have
with myeloma this is from a study from
the Mayo Clinic also very well in line
with what I see in my referrals in my
own clinic fatigue weight loss back pain
bone pain mild anemia mine anemia could
of course translate into fatigue for
example these are very diffused symptoms
diffuse abnormalities that could happen
in people with a lot of other conditions
and it could actually be just a normal
thing to being tired to be fatigued if
you have been working very hard so hold
it doctor no the patient does myeloma
these are difficult symptoms if you look
at where the presentation of these
patients what type of doctors actually
set the diagnosis of myeloma
this is from the 2007 study you see that
half the patients were diagnosed with
myeloma they were initially set the
diagnosis by a primary care in internal
medicine physician so really a lot of
patients are being diagnosed in that
setting if you know add these pieces
together we look at the duration it
takes to set the diagnosis and who
actually set the diagnosis you see the
general practitioners on the top of this
table the delay they're more than six
months on the right the column there
those are the 29 of the 51 patients that
were diagnosed by the general
practitioner so a lot of the delay
actually comes from that setting and
this is by no means here to accuse
anyone for doing anything wrong it's
just difficult and for general
practitioners that see patients with
very many different types of symptoms
and patients who have these symptoms for
other reasons how would the dog to be
able to tease out that these patients
actually had myeloma that's exactly why
I give this presentation today to try to
shed some more light on patterns that we
as doctors need to look for and think
about and don't forget about this he
sees myeloma that's relatively rare if
you look at the impact of delay this is
from the same study I just showed you on
the previous slide if you look to see
how the delay 3 into 0 to 3 3 to 6 or 6
and more months of delay how that
translates into complications you now
see that patients with six or more
months of delay that's where you have
most of the complications so if you wait
both of the complications that patients
have when they present according to this
study
the complications that they attract here
was anemia on the very right you see in
the light pink bar
you also see bone disease which is
similar to what I see in my clinic
patients could present with a fracture
renal failure this is also what I see in
my practice patient that could present
they get very very sick
they come to an emergency room somewhere
the doctors are working the patient up
to see what's going on and it turns out
the patient has very high creatinine or
the EGFR is very low they think of
hypocalcemia they think of other things
they do a lot of work up they don't
really understand what's going on they
run the total protein they see high
total protein and one thing leads to the
other and they do more blood work they
do bone marrow biopsy the patient of
myeloma they come to me and I treat the
patient these are things that I don't
think need to to be as common if we were
to be more attentive to the early signs
of the disease again I very much would
like to acknowledge that it's difficult
but I think just by talking about it and
repeating these messages hopefully there
are some patients that can be spared
from these complications and we can have
earlier detection last complications on
the slide here I would like to emphasize
these neurological and infections the
neurological I would think actually is
much higher I think that having
peripheral neuropathy is actually quite
common in these patients and I think
there is probably under reporting and
infections probably or also under
reporting I would think that these
probably are patients that had very
severe infections but if you start
looking into these patients many of them
have had maybe not as bad but pretty
frequent infections which in turn is
probably because of we continues this
what about more prominent types of
symptoms so let's start off with
skeletal pain because that's listed as
one of the main symptoms back pain is
probably most common type of
when it comes to the skeletal pain but
patients can have pain from other sites
I just saw a lady while ago who had hip
pain lady in her 60s she had gone to her
primary care physician and they thought
it was art roses going on they followed
her it got worse and worse and
eventually she was worked up she was
actually found to have a plasmacytoma
which had to be treated with
radiotherapy and then she was referred
to me and we followed her and
unfortunately she subsequently after a
few years of follow-up developed
multiple myeloma so sometimes things
that were less common can hide between
the common diagnosis but we need to
again be aware and think about these
things her symptoms worsened so that
triggered her primary care physician to
think about these types of things here
you see in the classical pictures of
pretty severe lytic bone lesions on the
left you see from the upper extremity a
lot of holes and on the right you see a
lot of holes in the skull and I'd like
to take the opportunity to say that
these pictures are old-school x-ray in
my practice I basically stopped doing
x-ray I no longer do the skeletal survey
I only do CT either I do low-dose CT or
PET CT the CT component in the past it
is probably 20 to 30 times more
sensitive for the detection of bone
disease than the skeleton survey so why
would we not do that both those two
modalities are approved by the
guidelines by the ímwg guideline the
reason that both are there is because
some countries they don't have access to
the load of CT or PET CT
so therefore the guideline have to be
open to different types of scenarios
when it comes to access but not only the
bone could carry evidence of disease of
this type here you see pictures by MRI
on the very left you see on the baseline
imaging by an MRI of the spine that
there is a focal infiltration and you
can you see if you look very closely
that the bone marrow is actually a
little bit more dense is more diffusely
infiltrated by plasma cells if you are
used to look at these types of pictures
in healthy people so you have a mix of
focal and diffuse disease and on this
slide you also can see in the middle
after complete response the patients
being treated and then on the right you
can see the patients as relapse the
reason I put this here is because I
wanted to remind you of the fact that
myeloma is action of the disease of the
bone it's the disease of the bone marrow
from the image we image the bones we
actually imaging complications of the
disease the disease is located in the
bone marrow so I think what needs to
happen in the coming future is that we
need better imaging modalities to to
track earlier changes of what's going on
in the bone marrow and there are a lot
of new tracers in developments you could
have MRI with the pet and maybe also pet
CDs where the tracer of the PET CT could
be more myeloma specific but this is
ongoing research for now but I think
this is probably going to happen in the
coming years before I move on to more
symptoms I want to take opportunity to
just give you a very brief update on
what's going on in the field of of the
cells here so when you put a needle into
the bone marrow you should always do a
core and an aspirin if you have access
to that the core will return on the
plasma cell infiltration and that will
be important if if you want to determine
anything MgO smoldering myeloma or
myeloma you want to look at the
percentage of those plasma cells the
aspirin that you can use to do an
aspirin smear we always inherently
underestimate the plasma cell
infiltration because you have a lot of
blood contamination that we dilute the
sample and in my experience it gives you
have the plasma cell percentage as you
would see with the correct method for
determination of plasma cell which is
the immune is - chemistry with CD 138
you can also run additional assays in
our practice we would run multi color
flow cytometry we will also do snip
arrays and we are entering the era of
sequencing which do we do for every
patient
if you look for patients samples with
the conventional immunity the chemistry
or here you have an aspirin smear you
see a range of cells in a normal person
while in the myeloma patient you see in
excess of these abnormal plasma cells so
this is how we still set the diagnosis
if you look for the abnormal plasma
cells when we do the more advanced
workup which is actually still quite old
at this time the flow cytometry is more
than 30 years or 30 40 years old we look
at individual cells we can get and see
what markers that we refined and then we
can use this and based on our knowledge
we can say there are abnormal cells
there light chain restricted and this
patient has actually evidence of an
abnormal plasma cell disorder these are
important tests in particular if you
have lower levels of plasma cells
because you cannot determine clonality
in a patient who have a low level plasma
cell infiltration under the microscope
you really need to do the flow test when
it comes through the details of the of
the disease what's going on
we know that patients that go from
earlier stages into myeloma and even if
they were to develop plasma cell
leukemia relapse disease that the
genetic signatures are different for
many years we have done fish inside of
genetics and this is also a very old
technology that more than 30 40 years it
should be a little bit direct here I
imagine I'm not sure why we still do
this because there is so much more
information to be gained we can split
patients into different subsets with
these type of tests but it's pretty
old-school new information using whole
exome the whole genome sequencing
reveals many more pieces of information
beyond these gains and losses as well as
the translocations that you can pick up
with fish and cytogenetics you can see
evidence of mutations that are recurrent
in myeloma we have these somatic
mutations and on this slide there are a
lot of genes listed on the right you see
Cara's and Russ and then you have
3d is 3046 see etc etc and on the very
left you see the bar sticking out 23 and
20 percent for chaos and M rot so that
tells you that a rat's mutation is
present in about 50% of patients that
you don't see if you do fish inside of
genetics and all the other genes are
just not covered at all so I think
what's going to happen is that we're
going to move into an era when people
are going to sequence patient we have
set up an ethical MyType where we
sequence every patient at baseline and
we capture all the information you would
get proficient cytogenetics
plus all the somatic mutations you see
on this slide and beyond I think that's
what the field the direction they feel
is going if you use these information
and you put it together you can actually
see that every patient that diagnosed
with myeloma has multiple parallel
subclones that are genetically diverse
so this really is very strong data
supportive of the use of combination
therapy for the treatment of myeloma you
only use one drug or targeted drug you
may get rid of a subset of the disease
but there are many parallels applause
now let's come back to the symptoms so I
started off telling you about the
diffuse symptoms fatigue back pain all
those types of things there are some
symptoms that or acute if they happen
patients would go to the doctor the
doctor we see these patients this is
severe pain patient who has spinal cord
compression also this patient could have
loss of motor activity in the extremity
could have problems with the
incontinence and even fecal incontinence
these patients need very very emergent
State they need to go to the emergency
room they need to be seen by a
orthopedic surgeon or a neurosurgeon we
would typically put them on high doses
of steroids and then send them right to
the operating room
if this patient you see in this slide
were to be left without any intervention
this patient will become paraplegic and
that would be devastating for this
patient if you take action right away
you can revert that and the patient can
go back and not have any of these
symptoms in the future so this is very
very important
hypercalcemia is another example of the
complication of the disease the part of
the diagnostic criteria you can and you
may or may not have it you have a
hypercalcemia you can develop a lot of
symptoms some of them are more acute you
can have arrhythmias heart blocks you
can have vomiting and then you can have
other things as well you can have muscle
weakness for example and the reflexes
can be decreased polyuria anorexia
hypertension can happen as well and I
could be EKG changes so this can be an
acute presentation as well sometimes I
see patients who come to the emergency
room they have acute kidney failure and
hypercalcemia at the same time so there
are some of these that go together
talking of kidney failure that's one of
the more common presentations in the
acute setting from myeloma that we see
here we have a picture of a kidney
biopsy from a patient who has myeloma
cast net property also referred to as
light chain cast neuropathy or sometimes
we casually call these and myeloma
kidney so you see the positions of these
light chain in the kidney structure and
I think in a simple way you could say
that the blood has these light chains it
runs in the body when it comes to the
kidney the kidney tries to clear the
blood and the kidneys usually can do a
pretty good job to get rid of these
proteins but as the concentrations go up
and also in all fairness some patients
are more sensitive than others so in
those people that are more sensitive the
kidneys can get clogged and then they
stop really cleaning and you store
developing kidney failure and then if
you do a biopsy this is what you see
this is very important
because this actually can be an acute
condition that can revert into a chronic
kidney injury that would make these
depositions turning into fibrosis of the
kidney typically as you see on the slide
presents as an acute injury and you can
do urine analysis and you see the light
chains if you look at patients who have
a very bad estimated glomerular
filtration rate highlighted in blue here
less than 30 that includes the patients
with severe renal impairment and even
patients who need to go on dialysis but
probably less common or it is less
common but the severe patients they need
immediate attention but also the people
in red 30 to 59 there are people there
you can rescue if you look at early
mortality in patients who present with
renal impairment you can see how the
EGFR split by the more than 60 59 to 30
or less than 30 translates into an
increasing risk of early death in these
patients
these are myeloma patients if you
actually look at patients in a broader
context if you look at patients who are
on dialysis here for any reason on the
left and then you look on the right
patients with multiple myeloma who are
on dialysis if you look at their median
survival is strikingly different this is
probably due to a lot of factors I would
think biologically and clinically if you
have myeloma that it's so bad so it
leads to dialysis you may be rundown
there may be other factors or organ
specific factors as well but
nevertheless the mortality as you can
see is strikingly poor for these
patients so the message here is for a
patient who presents with acute renal
failure you see highlight chains the
rapid diagnosis with early treatment is
really key save the kidneys and improve
the outcome so I think on a practical
note if a doctor were to work in an
emerge
a patient came in and had a rapid onset
of just severe illness the general
symptoms workup is done you show high
creatinine you don't really know what's
going on you run your light change you
see very high light chains put that
patient right away on fluid put a
patient on high doses of steroids you
can do a bone marrow biopsy you can set
the diagnosis of myeloma if you see that
there are plasma cells in the bone
marrow the kidney biopsy is actually
usually not required because you see
that you have the light change and you
will probably quite instantly see a
reversal of these changes so the kidney
biopsies definitely not needed there are
other reasons why patients could develop
renal failure we say hel plasma cell
disorders I don't have time to go into
all the different nuances of it but the
key one is the light change in the
kidney I showed you the other key one on
the right here is the al amyloidosis so
I al amyloidosis is also a monoclonal
gammopathy that manifests with
depositions of fibrils so these are
different types of proteins compared to
conventional immunoglobulins and the
light chain these are other types of
abnormal proteins that have the features
of being deposited into cells into
tissues so they don't run in the blood
but they go into tissues and or some
tissues they like more than others to be
in one of them is the kidney others
could be the fat in the abdomen and you
could also see that in the heart and you
could see it in other organs as well for
example in the stomach or in the
intestinal system for example and the
main focus of this slide is the lower
part here you can see that 80% of
patients with multiple myeloma are
present with intact
in you know problems these are the
monoclonal proteins in the middle you
see 15 to 20 percent of patients have
light chains only and then there is the
non secretory it says less than one to
two percent in my experience is probably
less than 1%
I would like to say or emphasize that
patients who do have an intact immune
globulin meaning patients who have an M
protein detectable by protein
electrophoresis and immuno fixation
probably 90% of those patients also have
an overproduction of light chains so
light chains are virtually in every
patient here and then there are 20% we
don't see em and proteins so if you want
to monitor these things you can do the
monoclonal intact immunoglobulins that
are either grams per liter and they can
also be grants per deciliter you do
serum electrophoresis and you only don't
buy immunity station for the isotype for
example IgG Kappa lambda or things like
that and for the monoclonal free light
chains the national unity is milligrams
per liter some institutions use
milligrams per deciliter in the old days
we used to do the urine electrophoresis
and that's how it initially was coined
and this is the Benz Jones proteins but
we can now use the blood test the serum
free light chain and I will show some
more details on how these tests they
perform head-to-head I would like to be
very practical and tell you from my
weekly a daily practice if you see a
patient that has been worked up at
another institution and now the patient
comes to your place if you run the light
chains be careful if you look at the
unit milligram per liter or milligram
per deciliter some labs have one or the
other
and if you run in one lab and it's 100
and now you see the patient is 10 that
looks great but if it's a conversion of
the of the units it's actually the same
amount of protein it goes the other way
around that could trigger a lot of
anxiety people think the patient is
progressing but it's again it's just the
unit and I see these very often so I
tell all my fellows what unions are we
talking about and then they have to go
back and look when you do the workup for
the monotron of intact immunoglobulins
on the left you have blood from a
healthy individual doing
protein electrophoresis on the right in
the mutant fixation and if you have a
patient with myeloma you see these
monoclonal protein sticking up in the
gamma region and then for the
minification electrophoresis you see
there is one band for IgG and there is
one from Kappa so here you have a
patient with an IgG Kappa monoclonal
problem or the free light chain assays
that we use in the blood you would run
both the Kappa and the lambda and the
normal references are here 3.3 to 19
which for milligram per liter if it were
to be milligram per deciliter it will be
zero point three three to one point nine
four you remove the decimal after lambda
you have the corresponding reference
work early on down by Jerry Katzman and
colleagues at Mayo Clinic define based
on their series arrange for the ratio
between Kappa lambda to be between zero
point two six to one point six five
that's a range that most people would be
in unless they have reasons such as
kidney failure where you could see
slightly higher numbers even in a
otherwise healthy person these assays
can fluctuate a lot so even if you saw a
one time national or the range over the
Nationals outside the range that doesn't
mean that the person all of a sudden
necessarily have a plasma cell dyscrasia
if you check again you get back to
normal that could be due to imbalance in
fluids or that could be a range of
things going on maybe there were some
drugs that put pressure on the kidney so
you need more than one data point what
is the or is urine immuno fixation in
the era of the serum free light chain
outside that's a very good question so
if you want to study proteins in the
urine because the the kidney does not
release the same amount of protein every
single minute you need to capture urine
for 24 hours these has been established
for a very long time so when we have
office or 24 hour urine it's very easy
to do that but when patient has
collect the urine for 24 hours and drag
it back to the office that's usually a
pretty big deal and I think it's
probably fair to say and I based on
based on very many years of a lot of
experience I think patients don't always
do that I think they bring back less
there is a lot of arrow there and I know
our lab if they get information that the
patient only did it for 15 hours or so
they would then do mathematical
extrapolation so they would say Oh 15
out of 24 hours that least 90% and then
they were stopped multiplying and do all
these types of things I think there's a
lot of error and his log inconvenience
so that led Gary catchment of Mayo to
look into this in a study so they had
four hunts who had a monoclonal protein
detected by during immunization so they
asked the question would you miss anyone
if you only do the serum based assays in
these patients and on the left you have
all the uranium you know fixation
positive cases these are the 428 cases
on the right you see that 99.3 and 99.5
of the percent of the patients in the
yellow group were captured if you did
serum protein electrophoresis and or
serum free light chain and the first one
and immuno fixation and free light chain
in the serum none of these are
significantly different and also the few
cases that were negative had very low
levels and they were a very low level of
M doses so I think on a clinical note
you would not miss anything if you did
not do 24-hour urine if you're looking
for the apply chains so the Mayo Clinic
has implemented this algorithm you can
screaming patients with serum protein
electrophoresis and a serum free light
chain these are the two tests you do not
need to do the urine test
you do not need to do the immuno
fixation test or screaming so if the
protein electrophoresis and the free
light chain have done if they are
positive then you
should do the immunity station because
you now need to see what type of you
know accession patterns we have what
isotype is is that ID kappa RDA lambda
for example if the patient is negative
if you still want to rule out al
amyloidosis the urine is useful so you
would now order a 24-hour urine immuno
fixation test this would be the
algorithm that Mayo Clinic has
communicated and we are using the same
algorithm so does all the other leading
sentence to my knowledge jerry catchment
published another paper in 2009 when
they look again at the diagnostic
sensitivity all the blood tests versus
the during immunisation electrophoresis
this was a larger retrospective study
where they looked at different screening
algorithms they had testing horses that
were selected on the basis of all having
matched serum and urine they had almost
2,000 patients on the next slide I will
show you results from 467 myeloma and
581 al amyloidosis patients and as you
can see here if you use serum protein
electrophoresis and serum free light
chain which is what I showed you for the
first study when they looked in patients
who had evidence by urine you capture
one hundred and ninety six point two
percent respectively so this data is
clearly very very strong and consistent
so when the International myeloma
working group wrote if guidelines in
2009 which is the international
consensus for how to monitor patients
guidelines state that the serum free
light chain assay in combination with a
serum protein electrophoresis and in you
know fixation yields a very high
sensitivity and make gate the need for
24 hour urine studies for diagnosis
other than al amyloidosis
so I can tell you in my practice that is
focusing on multiple myeloma and
precursor diseases of myeloma
what do we do all patients have come to
us because we are a
Perle center we would run the protein
electrophoresis we will run immunization
and the serum free light chain on every
patient and we would for the first visit
in our our practice because we are
specially focusing on these diseases we
will do a 24-hour urine collection and
random unification on that but for the
subsequent visit unless there is a
particular reason we would not repeat
the 24-hour urine we would just stick to
the serum based assays we would also
typically in our test panel do a protein
sorry a troponin test and an empty CRO
BMP test and those who test that we
would use to screen for amyloidosis or
involvement on the heart so I'm almost
at the end of my presentation so I
showed you the guidelines so how good
are people actually following these
guidelines well not as good as we could
be so this is from a presentation at
AACC where 741 laboratories responded or
what test combinations they use to
screen for patients who have a suspicion
of a protein abnormality and as you can
see in 80% of the instances they did not
include serum based light chain assay
only done so in 20% of them so there's
clearly a lot of under use of I think
this is the last data slide I have so
who orders most of the screens for
myeloma and who follows the guidelines
at the higher to a higher degree so the
answer to that question is if you start
on the left in blue who orders most of
them it is the internal medicine doctors
according to this presentation that was
presented in Edinburgh in 2015
close to 30% of the screen that were
done or ordered by internal medicine
Ballu them now who are the best doctors
to be compliant well a gold store goes
to the kidney doctors the nephrologist
had more than 50% in green here so I
think that's probably because they are
used to look for light chains so they
are thinking about it we still not 100%
there is room for improvement for sure
but I think the purpose of this graph
here is really not to say that once the
shallot is better than the other is just
to alert ourselves that things are not
perfect and people talking about these
things and remembering and that these
things actually can't happen
I think things can get better so it's
only it comes in a good place without I
would like to end my presentation and I
would like to thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to take any
questions you may have thank you dr.
Landon for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box down by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window
dr. langran will answer as many
questions as time permits and the first
question is these symptoms are so common
what would raise your suspicion for
multiple myeloma testing well so in my
clinical practice because again I'm a
referral center I a patient come to me
the suspicion is usually quite high so
that's probably not really the focus we
we have here today I think if I think of
myself working in a more general setting
in a general practitioners setting I
realized that a lot of patients come
there they have all these diffuse
symptoms I think anyone who comes and
say I'm a little bit tired and fatigued
they probably don't have myeloma I think
someone who has some kind of a
persistence if it happens a second time
to remember that myeloma could be one of
those things to throw in a protein
electrophoresis and a free light chain
test I think it's important and I think
the data here shows us that the average
patient will actually have myeloma has
delay of about six months and most of
that delay comes from the early work of
in the general practitioners office
because it's difficult it's very
difficult I think also from patients who
have certain types of symptoms if
patients had back pain all the back pain
is quite common unfortunately among
people in general we wouldn't like to
miss a severe complication I think it's
also pretty easy to throw in the protein
electrophoresis and the zero free light
chain test in patients who present with
back pain of course there are patients
maybe that you think of more commonly so
along those lines that you have an older
patient but sometimes younger patients
have that too in my practice I actually
see a lot of young patients my younger
patients right now are in their mid-20s
I have very many patients in their 30s
and in their 40s and I have patients in
the 50s 60s and up my older patients are
actually about the age of 80 the reason
I see a lot of young patients in my
clinic is because we're working at a
high-profile program so we have a lot of
newer drugs and very careful monitoring
so a lot of these young patients seek
our service so that's that's the reason
why we have a lot of them but it still
serves as a general reminder that
unfortunately less than 5% of patients
are diagnosed with myeloma or diagnosed
below the age of 50 so they are out
there and we don't want to miss any
patients you mentioned all of these
symptoms are there certain patients that
I should pay particular attention to
well I keep on saying the same thing
that this is difficult it's so diffuse
from many of these patients in the
beginning not until they start
developing fractures acute kidney
failure then it's kind of easy and you
don't want to go there so thinking of
these diffuse things and being alert and
thinking of ordering these tests in
general terms that's one thing but I
think there are certainly some patients
that probably if I think about these
things that would be even more prone to
think about this stuff and what I'm
thinking specifically about is
for example I mentioned that the
african-american population
unfortunately has about ten years
earlier age of onset for myeloma so if
we if I think about my training in med
school we were taught all these
different types of symptoms and we're
looking for diseases and you're kind of
as doctors we kind of are looking for
patterns we are trained to do pattern
recognition and if you have a young
patient you you may not think of myeloma
but I think if you have an
african-american patient in front of you
who is younger who has any of these
symptoms that patient could actually
have myeloma even if that's a younger
person I mentioned it could happen in in
in quotations or other ethnic or racial
groups as well but in particular
statistically speaking African Americans
are about 10 years younger on average
other types of patients that I probably
would think about are people who have
been exposed to certain types of the for
example chemicals
although the literature is not
completely definitive we and others have
done studies in farmers we have found
that people are exposed to chemicals
seem to have more myeloma and I let a
study a couple of years ago where we
looked through United States veterans
from the Air Force and the people who
were in Vietnam and conducted spraying
with Agent Orange they had much more of
early signs of disease and there is a
link with myeloma there as well and we
are working on other exposures as well
so I think there are people that have
certain exposures and there are certain
risk groups where I would think about
these things probably one extra round
should I still run 24-hour urine testing
24-hour urine testing I think is still
on the menu but I do think the serum
free lighting test is so much more
convenient it's much more reliable and
for the patient is
wait-wait-wait much more easy for the
patients so I would say that many of the
24-hour urine tests that are done around
the world every day probably could be
replaced by the serum free life change
if you go back and look at data there
was a publication about this year ago in
the blood journal where they I think it
was the French group they had compared
the 24-hour urine we'd be you know free
like China and they basically show that
there was no added value to do the
24-hour urine I showed here today
studies from the Mayo Clinic were they
in the screening setting showed that it
does not really add anything from the
detection of plasma cell discretions but
there could be other reasons for doing
these types of 24-hour testing so for
example if you're looking for
amyloidosis if you are looking for a
leaking kidney of broader spectrums of
proteins certainly the hearing test
would provide information that you don't
have in the blood so as I said before to
make sense of this and to be practical
in my clinical practice at our practice
at Memorial sloan-kettering we do blood
work with serum free light chain protein
electrophoresis because we are referral
center we upfront do the immuno fixation
so we don't miss that but for the
screening purpose that's not necessary
if you find something if you do that as
the second step if a patient is negative
to go forward and do the urine a 24 hour
in the screening setting it would be
appropriate but for us as a referral
center we would do it upfront as well so
our batteries protein like rhesus
unification we do students rely 10 and
24 hour urine for baseline but
longitudinally we would not do the 24
hour urine to just be clear again for
the general practitioner I think the
serum free light chain and the protein
electrophoresis should be sufficient to
screen for and there should not be any
need
24-hour urine unless there is a
particular question so I give you kind
of my perspective as a specialist in
myeloma and I give you the general
practitioners perspective as well I
would like to once again thank dr.
Lander and for his presentation
do you have any final comments I think
yeah we had a very fun time here and you
ask really good questions from the
audience I really really appreciate
thank you so much for having me thank
you again and I would also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker
afterward we would like to thank our
sponsor binding site for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through March 21st 2018 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye